vesti
olistico
differen olistico
tesica
un muscolo forte muscolo indicatore
forte muscolo frago se muscolo forte fig
forte essa categoria è
presen test significativo se o muscolo
Troca stato muscolare da forte sfiga
frag se
non
negao
neo non identific
frago la chinesiologia qualche
chinesiologia chesia medica appc qual
chinesiologia signica significa Cid
Significa
significa
muscolare seolo frago frago frago Aho no
POS Claro perch C una droga di St
muscolare se per esempio tessi
contrario testi muscolo
frago frag
Force poso non perché muscolo F Force
perché muscolo fu FR muscol
for
io con sempre un idioma ch etologico non
posso farla Force frago frago Force
perché l'important lbr sempre se un test
è positivo su test negativo Iso
Eh una Confusion
problema SP sempre solo che poss prenda
test positivo TR stato muscolare test
negativo stato muscolare che se già
forte se frago non importa non importa
essere positivo se un muscolo fuori
forte frago
F for Sì sì
mto devo Sì facendo
ttico pa no qualche
categoria categoria
problemas
studi che Cont se muscolo indicato io
usato è forte Ess negativo muscol forte
FR
positivo
vcolo
indicatore
mus
Tesis qualche muscolo qualche lato
studi sistema
CR
CAP
muscolo
esio
diagon no
diagon eh è forte poi Us
muscolo muscolo scher
Eh la m vpr come si Chama
Mancino manino Peretto cagot cagot eh
cagot cnot cagot
Lav sinistra come si
chiama Coto Coto cagot che e un Coto
corretto che significa is
ver cnot ma mamai
me la forzatura
usire io consigli
bene SCH Sol cheo
Goto ogetto sbagliare Chi è Cagnotto Chi
è Cagnotto che
Goa Mel sbagliando schero CH è cagot
quio
F mesmo
mesmo su
che
testi
Fren testi che
preciso Nuo
indic
indic Prim
Cali a nostra Cali i calibr forza sopra
forza un po tes
for
poniz consulta
perché calibro non calib
forza muito o Minus o
mais Boh allora calibrato sopra forza
caraz
differ Primero
convincimento
qualche
[Musica]
muscolo
musol
for Imp forte forte Ess lib è
impossibile
e
e da fars perché muscolo Chia perché per
mi per
mai mudanza di forza muscolare È l'unico
muscolo che permo per esempio Perm for
fragata Come si chiama forma
anatomica
unaa cibo prica
posso io Perché te sensibilità che non
priso No però ecco sto percependo vela
che che sta facendo un B
Tesio
con Ecco non
fì Luc la nostra consulta Luc Limo
nuglio n luisotti n pazien che grida Fun
m esposa esposo nada
nch
è
una distra Eh io non consigo io consigo
insomma non St con la musica come si
chiama zumpi zumpi zumpi zumpi zumpi
musica tecno Come si Chama Tecno
Tecno qual qual F di
disturbio limpo Luis for per esempio la
corda
branc peré una neutra No una parete
vermiglia vermeglio cioè che significa
pazen parete
vai No che vai la risposta muscolare
visto un lug sua consulta neutro eh
neutro
secondo Altura maga maga caso è Bu
perché son da come si
Chama c stof stof stof e
sta la
Altura Se io
fossi mai salto
deviglia
for famiga se fossi basso per esempio
Mauro Mauro non pua perché è alta è mto
alta abbasci un po' con la mano eh e
Alin che è alto eir che è alto che sei
non sai come poss Pine Pine che
B po mess impossibile
o contr regul
fazar né Sem ser
elétrica Ah verdade aqui faz O que quer
Como que Eu vou Fazer Tem que resetar
minha Maca
resetar Maca é pco difil is
que me ajuda a teacher é dou ajuda Tem a
marca eletr Eu também Tem elé a z 500 é
magnético se tirar l se tirara da Tomada
no anula o problema é o magnete magnete
do modor ah o modou verdade a maquina
eletrnico Eu tenho Ela Tem D PR Fazer El
modou S
modou
modou modou que pode interferir Nos
testes Eu Mou Eu Mou é
modou O ncle como se Chama Ele Tem uma
uma P
bobbina Sì bobbina copri
copri è una
Mag magn
Magneto
perch peraz
se
Cont
sein
deixa
geopatia tipo Eu que mentes
estati estran per non è
possib statistica geop
10%
Magisto
e che
[Musica]
fnn siamo scollare per
esempio non Paz
Paz per
esempio
Busca forza non forza
non F sospetto che da B sta un nodo che
amaca 50 C suffici testa CH
B A chi sta
perché so un nodo un
nodoo è unia acuta non è cronica
problema è
acess momento quando
fig gente saese
sospetto puscia un poco
eh marito Marito e
cammin parea de
doid circular Sal
impur impur impur impur
impur
[Musica]
po
suo marito eh ah sì siuro
cheur eh
marito consulta eh for forte For for
forte a chi è Bon a chi è Bon a chi è
Bon a chi è Bon a chi non è
Bon
piove
pi
Allora nostra
amica Mas é nesse caso é é os lado de
frio